the front door slammed with a gusty bang
and Julia Lathrop jumped nervously
dropping the book she'd been reading
from the hallway came the sound of a
child's clear treble than light running
feet Virginia Julia called trying to
suppress the strange quaver in her voice
the sudden heart beating of her heart
that yoojin corsets me mother and chin
came into the room the child was thin
like a growing Reed awkwardly graceful
and tall for her nine years she was
proud of her missing front tooth and her
- taffy colored braids which were still
too short really to ever stay braided
Julia noted the look of luminous
happiness on the child's delicate face
the wind ruffled hair like a fine spun
web the two bright eyes that had of late
become a little secret and remote must
you darling slam the door when you come
in it wasn't me Jen protested a trifle
sulkily Virginia well but it wasn't it
was Tommy really he came in when I did
but he ran right out again Julia's lips
tightened a little as she studied the
child's face she could discern nothing
but candor there Virginia's hurt air of
being misunderstood seemed real enough
Virginia you're not to tell that story
again do you hear it's silly just
something you made up there isn't any
such person and you know it I know it's
just a game but it's a wicked one
Virginia stamped her foot her childish
face contorted with grief and anger two
huge tears squeezed out of her stricken
eyes and worked their way down her
smooth Apple cheeks it isn't she sobbed
it isn't just a story it's true every
bit
Tommy's real we played tag in the
orchard before we came in he isn't a fib
I didn't make anything up I didn't
frightened Julia jumped up and crossed
the room in quick strides she grasped
the thin heaving shoulders and looked
down into gins tearful accusing face
trying to mask the unsteadiness in her
voice she spoke casually don't do that
Jenny don't cry mother didn't mean
anything bad here's a hanky that's
better isn't it her fingers flew
smoothing the fine toffee colored hair
you must have been playing tag with the
wind look you've lost a ribbon and torn
your skirt Tommy runs faster than me
said the child more calmly I chased him
but he got away in the briar patch I
guess that's how I tore my new dress
suddenly Julius swept the taffy colored
head clothes she didn't want gin to see
her face just then seems to me Julia
said gaily this Tommy of yours is always
running away he must be quicker than a
rabbit is that why I've never seen him
Oh mother he's scared of people yes and
why because well because the childish
voice trailed off the room was very
quiet
Julia stiffened staring fixedly over
Jen's bowed head staring through the
wide open casement windows at the clean
warm yellow afternoon sunlight beyond
the white sashes were the masked blooms
of the hollyhocks trim precise and sane
beyond the flower bed she could see a
shaven slope of lawn and still further
away the ripe grass uncut at the foot of
the old orchard the orchard she thought
frantically forcing herself to think was
frightfully rundown the twisted wind
tortured trees assumed such grotesque
shapes at night those dead husks should
have been cut down long ago they were
unsightly and spoiled the place the
orchard field itself was grown over with
lank weeds and sparse wild hay that had
seated itself on the wind
she watched how the window of a path
through the tall grass of the orchard
field invisible feet retreating from the
edge of the lawn back toward the shadows
of the twisted apple trees
she watched intently how the yellow
grass rippled at the base of a gnarled
trunk and a big City crow suddenly
flapped from a dead limb rancorous lee
crying
at first julia had been crazy about the
place the sprawling white house on a
hilltop had seemed exactly what they
were looking for the land itself was
considerably rundown but for that reason
rather wild very charmingly diversified
and not really like a farm at all cliff
laughter up had joked to their friends
about their recently acquired 30 acre
estate it had he proudly boasted a hill
a gully a house a red barn a private
road and orchard no good a strip of
woods second growth and a private
springfed Lake yes the pond really a
lake to their city-bred eyes had just
about clinched the sale it lay in a
hollow behind the house and at the base
of the hill far enough away so that they
were not really troubled with mosquitoes
that must have bred in the strip of
swamps that surrounded the pond the
swamp didn't matter for it was not
unsightly thick rhododendron grew there
a massive pink bloom in the late spring
and there were trees and ferns at purple
iris in the muddy shallows of the water
grew thin tall sedge grass water lilies
and graceful cattails a shallow Ridge of
clear dry ground maybe once an old wagon
road led from the house itself down
through the woods to a small floating
dock built by some previous owner they
had planned such a grand summer but
Julia was beginning now to hate the
place even in the bright sunlight she
could remember suddenly and shiver
wondering if after all the place was
really some sort of trap in which slowly
sanity slipped away until at last you
came to accept as a matter of course
that which was beyond reason or
credibility Virginia what was happening
what in heaven's name was wrong with the
child from the first just as they had
hoped she had blossomed happily in the
clean country air frolicked and played
from dawn to dusk but Julia watchful and
puzzled alert to every nuance of
strangeness in Jin's behavior could no
longer deny to herself that there was
something weirdly wrong with the child
for either gin had become obsessed with
some vast elaborate and very complicated
kind of lying or else but the
alternative she refused steadfastly to
permit herself to believe even yet
but why be upset cliff asked innocently
when at last Julia brought herself to
speak to him about Jen's lying kids are
always making up things it's only
harmless imagination working overtime it
isn't exactly julia said slowly choosing
her words with a certain amount of care
and you mustn't scold her about it it
has the strangest effect she gets upset
terribly unnerved and it frightens me
because well because I can see that she
really believes in this imaginary
playmate oh you don't know what it's
been like it frightens me
but I didn't want to say anything to you
until I was really sure Cliff's mouth
opened he looked at his wife curiously
sure of what of her belief you mean well
suppose she does believe sort of in this
fictitious Tommy maybe she's lonely
maybe he's real in a sort of way to her
childish imaginations you know the way
people in fairy tales were real to her
when she was younger it's just a fad and
she'll outgrow it maybe get tired of the
game when she sees we don't take it very
seriously seems to me that's the thing
to do teas are out of it not pull a long
face and get all wrought up about
something that doesn't even exist but at
dinner Eclipse teasing brought
unexpected results well I hear
Virginia's got a bow a Julia Cliff
winked at his wife ladling at a liberal
helping of cold chicken for the child
young man name of Tommy our so I've been
told who told you Virginia's clear eyes
clouded with suspicion
the bantering tone was evidently not to
her liking who told me cliff mocked his
small daughter well now is it a secret
yes the child answered with a scowling
glance at her mother sort of oh well
since the secret's out now might we be
told where the young gentleman lives
seems to me he must do quite a
cross-country hike to get out here from
well wherever he's from oh no the
child's eyes round and serious were
vaguely troubled she hesitated then as
though under some dim necessity to make
herself somehow understood added quietly
you wouldn't understand
he lives right nearby you see Oh some
little boys staying at the Jackson farm
daddy don't be silly
he lives right here on our place in the
and that's where he goes when he goes
back in again and I know cuz I've seen
him not again that evening did they make
any reference to Jin's queer obsession
for otherwise the child behaved normally
enough cliff played checkers with his
small daughter and allowed her to beat
him twice after that she went happily
and triumphantly to bed
afterward with the child asleep upstairs
and the eerie moonlight glistening like
frost on the clipped lon Julia abruptly
drew the curtains over black panes
heaven knows said cliff amused we've no
lack of privacy out here I was just
jittering Julia confessed unable to tell
him just then how she had felt that
overpowering warning instinct of being
watched of not being alone that the
moonlit lawn had been bare without blur
shadow had only made the feeling somehow
more terrible cliff what are we going to
do about Djinn well I think she's lonely
you ought to send for one of her friends
having some other kid around will chase
this funny idea out of her head quick
enough what say I've thought of that
Julia told him I've already sent for
Elsie she's at the seashore now but her
mother wrote that she can come out and
stay with Djinn for a week or two Oh
cliff you don't think there's something
wrong I mean that she really sees things
sick you mean no she's healthy as a
chipmunk eats like a little pig and
sleeps like a log say old girl did it
ever occur to you the little tyke might
after all be real up the road a piece
past Jackson's there's a Lithuanian
family plenty of kids all the sordid
ages must be one of them but cliff three
miles away
and besides what's three miles to a
country kid and you've never seen him
because he's shy I see but you act as if
everything's natural and maybe he'll
show up one morning with his paw out for
a cookie Oh cliff you think so well it
might be so personally I think we've
been letting Jin's well-developed
imagination run away with us scaring
ourselves and without any reason now
look there's only one sensible view to
take either he's a myth and she'll
outgrow it or else there really is such
a kid but he's scared and over shy in
either case what's terrible about it
Cliff's reasoning steadied her but only
for a moment for it was not only that
Julia had watched the child racing
across the lawn followed apparently by
none but the wind gleefully shouting and
calling to someone who never answered it
was not only that for countless days now
gin had stubbornly persisted in her
pretense that she was never really alone
anymore that always an invisible child
was at her side sharing in her childish
games it was more to it an indefinite
but horrifying more the one bit that
Julia had held back from cliff the day
before she had seen the invisible
playmate in bright sunlight grass
rippling gently
as though some small animals stirred at
its roots a small furtive round like the
passage of a snake she julia had crossed
the lawn to call Jen for lunch the child
was sitting quietly under a big beach
umbrella making a crude crayon sketch
Julia smiling and looking down average
in shoulder saw the scrawled likeness of
a little boy in blue overalls Jin had
made a round jack-o'-lantern face
wreathed in an exaggerated grin she had
drawn in fixed stubby hair of bright
reddish orange and made the feet bare
all at once Julia had been breathlessly
conscious that there was someone else
someone standing in the orchard field
just behind her someone so dim and
indistinct and when she turned her head
it was as though colors flickered in the
bright sunlight wavered and vanished
like an abruptly dissolving Mirage but
for one breathless instant for one
heartbeat she had seen something
something surely a wavering image like
the warping of air in heat haze the
shadow of a small figure standing in the
ripe grass of the field it had seemed to
Julia that the dissolving vision held
color blue tint like faded overalls a
white shirt a face unseen because it was
surmounted by a big hat of yellow straw
but afterward when fingers pressed to
her eyes she tried to recall details
that had been blurred only shadowy
suggestion Julia wondered whether she
had not merely imagined it heat and
glaring sunlight distort vision perhaps
she had simply projected in vision the
blue overall boy of Jin's child a sketch
the drawing she had carefully labeled in
angular block letters Tommy
it was with unutterable joy that julia
welcomed elsie the two children were of
the same age had been neighbors in the
city but curiously virginia exhibited no
great enthusiasm at seeing her old
playmate again she was indifferent and
ignored the other child I won't stay
here anymore
Elsie cried one morning storming into
the kitchen in tears I hate it here I
want to go home please
Oh Elsie what's the trouble did you and
Jin quarrel again no it's that ugly
horrible boy he spoils everything Elsie
Julia snatched the child's arm and swung
her sharply toward her you saw him
of course I saw him Elsie looked annoyed
what do you mean he comes every day but
he won't come near us he just stands
there watching or follows us around and
it's scary
I threw stones at him but they didn't
hurt him he just laughed and wouldn't go
home and Jin said she hates me she said
I scared him and now he won't come and
play until I go back home with Elsie's
abrupt leaving the household became to
all appearances normal again Jin's
impatience to be rid of the encumbering
Elsie had been only too evident now the
invisible other returned remained at her
side throughout all of the long summer
day Jin laughed and prattled and was
happy and under the apparent
light-hearted gaiety julia was aware
that horror hid and slowly uncoiled as
day slid in today even cliff now began
looking strangely at his small daughter
once or twice Julia found him staring
intently through the window saw him
start nervously as she entered the room
grinned sheepishly in turn away in an
embarrassed fashion it was he who urged
that she take Jin to a specialist and
Julia acquiesced because she thought
that a trip to the city might be good
for the child the outcome was only what
she might have expected Jin's fantasies
said the doctor did appear to be of a
somewhat hallucinatory nature but she
julia must not become alarmed the child
was in good health and should remain at
home she should not be punished or
forced in any way to relinquish her
queer obsession that might have harmful
consequences
Julia must be patient and endeavour to
lead her back to reality by pretending
for the moment to fall in with her
make-believe it Jen persisted in her
obsession or if the hallucinations
became more alarming
they would probably have to resort to
other measures driving back Julia
reflected that doctors were all very
well but after all she knew best she had
not told them one rather important thing
the chins fantasies had had reality of a
sort for at least two other people the
one useful bit of advice that the doctor
had given her only represented a
decision that she had already made that
if she were to save her little girl from
madness or something even worse she must
do it from now on through love and guile
gently and with patience she must win
the child away from that hated other
I've seen the little devil cliff told
her that evening when they were alone
again Julia looked blank that kid he
went on Jin's friend oh he was here I'll
say he was here last evening after you
left I caught the little tyke standing
on the lawn staring up at the windows it
wasn't sundown yet there was plenty of
light he looked quick how did he look
cliff frowns swallowing a little his
eyes betrayed vague puzzlement when he
spoke again he seemed to be choosing his
words very carefully why about like any
little country boy blue patched overalls
bare feet carried a frayed straw hat in
his hands he had a mop of red hair that
seemed to need cutting maybe he had
freckles too he'd come for gin Julia
laughed shakily and that's all that
happened well no I went to the door and
told him gin had gone to the city I'll
be damned if his face didn't screw up
with the most horrible look of hate he
shook his small fist at me and began
crying Oh cliff did he threaten anything
him cliff scratched his head again he
seemed hesitant and a little sheepish as
though he were withholding something of
which he felt uncertain or a little
ashamed hell he was only a little shaver
about an inch taller than gin I'd say
but there was something downright well
pitiful about him in some way I got the
idea then he thought Virginia gone away
for good
so I went onto the porch and told him to
quit sniveling gin would be back the
next day and then and then I took a few
steps toward him he turned around and
ran out on the road
I followed but when I got to the road
there wasn't a thing in sight still when
I went back to the house I had the
feeling that he hadn't ever left at all
I think somehow he was hanging around
all night but that's nuts isn't it if
I'd caught him though I'd have twisted
his blamed ear off and you know what for
the first time since we came out here I
was sorry we didn't have a dog a big
savage one she could foresee now a
fierce tug-of-war for the possession of
gin and as the struggle became more
intensified that other became less
cautious as Julia had hoped he emerged
into the open at last by great patience
she had managed to meet her antagonist
face-to-face it happened in this way
determined to be with Jin as much as
possible from now on she had suggested
to the child that they pack a picnic
basket
Daan bathing suits and spend the day at
the pond the suggestion seemed to
startle Jin yet please her I don't know
she had objected uncertainly Tommy lives
there he he needn't be afraid of me dear
let him join us there we can all spend
the day together then wouldn't that be
nice and if you'll just tell him he has
nothing to fear from me ever and that I
want to be friends I would love a swim
Genet interrupted down at the pond so
presently they were sitting on the edge
of the water soaked float dabbling bare
feet in the bright water it was a
perfect summer day hot and breathlessly
still the water blue in the ponds deep
center was brown in the shallows dappled
green with thick lily pads
Virginia squealed happily as she lowered
herself into the cold water paddling at
the edge of the float and showing off
the new stroke her father had taught her
all at once Julia was aware of something
standing in the muddy shallows just
behind someone stealthily watching half
hidden by the thin tall reeds very
matter-of-factly Julia turned her head
forcing herself to smile at the vision
hello she said calmly I'm glad you came
at last we've been waiting for you Jin
and I won't you come sit with us out
here Tommy
Virginia crowed holding to the edge of
the float with one hand and waving
frantically at the small furtive figure
in the reeds Tommy come on look I can
swim a little on my back Tommy look
like some small cautious animal the
child very slowly left the Reedy
shallows where he was crouching and
clambered up onto the bank he shuffled
across the bear strip of ground behind
the float and stood there to all
appearances bashfully hesitant grinning
and squirming his bare toes in the dry
earth there seemed nothing malevolent or
remarkable about him now he was small
Julius saw indeed scarcely bigger than
Jen herself he seemed a bit thin or
spindling or else his faded patched
overalls and quaintly cut shirt were a
little too big for him this time he
carried his big straw hat and she could
see his face quite plainly a grinning
engaging freckled face surmounted by an
unruly mop of red hair worn long ish in
the style of another time won't you come
near us Julia repeated her invitation a
little faintly no ma'am
she heard the boy distinctly say still
grinning eyes lowered as though in shy
embarrassment bare toes wriggling a
pattern in the dry dust suddenly Julius
stood up as though in pleading she
stretched out her hand took three quick
steps across the bobbing float toward
the small smiling child on the bank he
looked up then and the hatred and the
blue eyes leapt out at her stabbing
child why do you hate me I wouldn't harm
you don't you know that I only want to
know the truth why you are this way and
what I can do to help you be at peace he
was gone quite simply he turned his back
step toward the reeds and melted into
their midst disappeared the float rocked
as gin dripping and clumsy heaps herself
out of the water why he's gone Jen said
reproachfully a mother you drove him
away again
it was hot there was such a dazzle on
the water the sky was a tight lacquered
bowl everything was too still too close
too bright Julia clutched despairingly
at Jin's small dripping figure what's
the matter mommy the childish voice full
of puzzled concern made Julia break into
uncontrollable weeping do you feel awful
bad
Julia sobbed clutching Jen the harder
awfully bad my poor little girl don't
leave me ever you'll promise
stay close beside me of course I'm right
here mommy
Jen
applied with childish dignity I'm sorry
you hurt shall I dip some water out of
the pond and put it on your head the
pond No let's go back and don't ever go
near it again keep away from it you hear
it's cursed
the time had come julia felt when she
could no longer continue the unequal
struggle for now with every passing hour
she was losing gin was slowly but surely
slipping away from her only one
alternative remained to go away and now
she was forced to tell cliff the truth
I've been thinking about telling you for
two days
cliff unexpectedly informed her I know
all about it
I've been inquiring around ever since
that afternoon when I saw the kid he
looked at Julia Bleakley yeah I really
knew then something was wrong it's the
pond kid name of Tom Bofill drowned
there nine years old he was and that was
70 years ago 70 years julia repeated
with dry lips yes I saw how it must have
been the old-fashioned haircut the
quaint shirt he wore they never found
him cliff went on the family moved away
then a childless couple had the place
never noticed anything wrong then the
old bachelor coot we bought the place
from it's my fault I should have sent
you and Jen away before but now this
clinches it start packing tomorrow no I
won't even pack at least nothing but a
small suitcase
we won't let Jim know until the last
minute even then maybe we'd better
pretend we're just going for the day
after we've gone you can board up the
windows see that our things get moved
Julia clapped her hand over her mouth
suppressing a scream he was there she
cried frantically pointing to the wide
open window he heard us every word cliff
swore savagely he leaped to the door and
flung it wide open to the night across
the lawn trotted a small shape and
distinctly seen by the light of a
gibbous moon a small lad and overalls
who turned his head once looking back as
if in derision the instant cliff stepped
outside the door he had vanished
tomorrow
Julia choked tomorrow if it isn't too
late
they didn't leave because during the
night Virginia complained of a burning
in her throat by morning she was running
a high temperature and babbled
deliriously alarmed Julia had sent for a
physician but the man a local
practitioner advised against moving the
child until the fever had died down he's
won again Julia thought frantically he
doesn't want her to go away
but if chin had to remain confined in
that hateful house she could still watch
over her
never would that hated other get near
the child again already she had lost too
much to him ghin sanity and perhaps her
life itself
that sinister malignant child of the
pond would never dare set foot over the
threshold of the house so long as she
Julia remained on guard alert and
vigilant to the shadowy enemy he came in
the early afternoon
quite simply she knew that he was there
outside and sure enough when she went to
the door there stood the little overall
dad straw hat set askew on his head face
up tilted to the windows Jin's window
Julia walked out on the porch and slowly
he lowered his head staring full at her
with bright blue eyes he let her get
within eight feet of him then turned and
walked away wait Julia cried sternly
stand where you are he looked back over
one shoulder under the shadow of the
wide-brimmed hat she could see his eyes
sly taunting she could see the wide
mocking grin it seemed to her that she
had never known anything more malevolent
more horrifying than that child's face
thin freckled and full of an unshielded
wisdom and knowledge of something beyond
her a power she was utterly unable to
cope with stop she sobbed please let me
speak just once the other stopped Julia
considered flinging herself at him but
before she could move the lad solemnly
raised his hand and beckoned to her then
looking back and again beckoning he led
her deliberately across the field and
down the hillside toward the orchard why
cry Julia breathlessly when at last he
permitted her to overtake him why are
you doing this what do you want
the lad lowered his eyes I ain't gonna
be alone he muttered not no more he
looked up and again she felt the stab of
those blue child's eyes you want to take
her away but she ain't going she'll be
like me and she'll stay here forever
you want her to be dead Julia screamed
she is dead the lad answered now already
go see the house was empty gin and her
feverish delirium must have left while
the other lured Julie away
distraught weeping she ran from room to
room mocked everywhere by the ringing
echoes of her own voice the pond was
that what he had meant Julia ran
stumbling down the rough trails swamped
out through the patch of woods
she found gins to small shoes set side
by side on the edge of the pond in
response to her hysterical telephone
call cliff came home others too came to
console her or join in the search
close-mouthed men strangers tramped over
the fields the woods were combed at
night as the search spread to the
surrounding hills there was the mournful
baying of hounds get some sleep
cliff begged maybe there's still a
chance no she sobbed tell him not to
look anymore she's in the pond I know it
they'll drag tomorrow
cliff whispered haggardly we'll see
sometime in the night it began raining
julia slept but sleep was more terrible
than waking reality she plunged awake
out of a choking nightmare to the drab
grayness of earliest morning and the
sound of rain in the eaves downstairs
cliff slept huddled in a chair he had
not even taken off his shoes the
telephone had remained mute throughout
the night Julia tiptoed past him down
the hall and out the door it had rained
heavily a chill light glistened on every
leaf and blade Julia raised her face to
the cold drops feeling them soothe the
terrible throb in her head the ache in
her eyes she shut her eyes and walked
blindly feeling she could never get
enough of the cold pelting rain mommy
her eyes flew open then she cried out
and ran sobbing brokenly toward the
small figure standing uncertainly in the
rain and the grey mist gin I knew you'd
come back I
you wouldn't leave me forever don't come
any closer mommy Jen said please Oh Jin
let me hold you just once
Jin shook her head you can't mommy but
I've got to go now
Tommy's waiting the child turned and
with elfin grace glided off into the
rain
Julia ran stumbling often as the wet
grass tangled about her feet Jin ran to
fled barefooted with the speed of the
wind in the eerie grayness she seemed
part of the silver rain part of the mist
flowing along the tops of the wet grass
her two short braids drenched and dark
swung out behind her as she ran in the
milky opacity another child barefoot and
over auld raced to her side and joined
hands with her children wait please
Julia shrieked
she ran stumbling through the rain and
always the children hands clasped were
just a little ahead she lost them
presently and found bewildered that once
again he had ventured down the trail to
the edge of the pond she turned away
from the loathe side of the water gray
and pelted with raindrops weeping
blinded she stumbled against a solid
body a pair of arms and circled her good
god Julia cliff said hoarsely what are
you trying to do come on back quick now
Virginia Julia wept earth bound on
hallowed forever and ever I heard you
scream said cliff saw you running across
the field in the rain I yelled and
yelled but she didn't stop faintly and
very far away a dog began to bark Julia
twisted loose from Cliff's embrace
pointed to the wet earth cliff stiffened
his face slowly whitening two sets of
tracks the fresh prints of small bare
feet led into the pond even as they
looked they were already beginning to
fade under the pelting drops of the cold
heavy rain
[Music]
there's a small village on the Island of
Hawaii called
Ola nobody would ever guess the terrible
secret this village holds following the
accidental drowning of a young boy many
years ago today the tragedy still haunts
the villagers and their children back in
1947 a group of kids were playing on the
banks of a deep pond outside the village
one boy accidentally tripped over a log
and fell into the water with a splash
before any of the other children could
react the boy sank beneath the water
shimmering surface for a few moments
they waited for him to resurface but
there was no sign of him horrified they
ran back to the village to get help some
local men came as fast as they could and
dived into the pond searching for the
young boy they were terrified by what
they found
the boy was sitting on a rock at the
very bottom of the pond his arms were
hanging down by his sides and his body
was swaying back and forth with the
currents his eyes were wide and his
mouth was hanging open but he was dead
in the water the eerie sight sent
shivers down the spines of the men who
had dived in to save him they were
deeply disturbed and said it was such an
unusual way to drown It was as if the
boy had calmly sat down on the rock and
waited there to die they retrieved the
corpse and dragged it onto the bank of
the pond everyone who lived in the
village was saddened by the tragedy but
after the funeral they tried to put the
strange death behind them
afterwards bizarre rumors began to
spread around the area in the middle of
the night villagers would hear
unexplained screams and cries coming
from the direction of the pond at first
they tried to tell themselves that the
haunting cries were just caused by the
wind blowing through the tall trees
however as time went on some people
started to report disturbing experiences
whenever people walk past the pond at
night they would feel something reaching
out and trying to grab their feet many
villagers believe that the ghost of the
drowned boy lurked beneath the dark
waters of the pond they said that at
night he would come to the surface cold
wet and shivering his icy hands
clutching at unsuspecting victims and
trying to pull them into his watery
grave
according to the rumors he was trapped
in this world by accident and the only
way he could escape was to find someone
else to take his place at the bottom of
the pond one day a boy was out walking
with his father when they passed by the
haunted pond the boy picked up some
stones and skimmed them across the
surface of the water suddenly the boy
screamed out in terror something was
holding his leg and dragging him into
the pond the boy clawed at the earth
trying to hold on but it was no use
before his father had a chance to grab
hold of him the boy was pulled down into
the watery depths the desperate father
jumped into the pond and tried to find
his son but there was no trace of him
minutes later he dived deeper and
finally located the young boy he was
sitting on a rock on the bottom of the
pond arms placidly at his side's eyes
and mouth wide open swaying gently to
and fro in the current the father
grasped his son and pulled him up to the
surface he made his way to the edge of
the pond dragging his son behind him
like a dead weight
luckily the father had taken some
courses in first aid and there on the
bank he was able to perform
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation on his son
the man did everything he could and
finally just when he was about to give
up
he saw his sons chest rise and fall and
the boy coughed up all the water in his
lungs
the boy was alive after that all of the
parents in the village warned their
children to stay away from the pond a
priest was brought in to bless the
waters and the local people felt that
would put an end to the haunting
however on particularly dark nights when
the evening skies were as black as ink
those who lived closest to the pond
claimed they could still hear the boy's
terrifying screams some say that he will
never find peace nowadays nobody dares
to venture close to the pond and every
child in the village knows the story of
the drowned boy no one knows when that
goes toll once again grow restless and
try to claim another young life before
we begin I would like to clarify
something I would not be here right now
if I didn't feel it was necessary I'm
not one of those people who takes to the
Internet to rant and rave at the
slightest inconvenience
although the likelihood of anyone
believing this is slim hopefully someone
out there will heed my words my name is
Emily and my son Daniel has been killing
people now I know what you might be
thinking why come out with it like this
why not unburden your soul with a
confession or perhaps tell the police
it's not exactly that simple
Daniel lost his battle with muscular
dystrophy six months ago
you're probably scratching your head in
confusion right now I don't blame you if
it didn't happen to me I probably
wouldn't believe it but I promise you
every word is true it all began years
ago when my son was just a small boy due
to his health he could never really play
sports so he made up for it by playing
video games I can still remember the
look on his face that Christmas when I
got him a Super Nintendo at that point
he wasn't in a wheelchair yet he must
have tripped at least five or six times
sprinting as best he could over to the
Christmas tree clutching onto the box as
if it were made of pure gold
his favorite game at the time was Super
Mario Brothers he would come home from
school get his homework done as fast as
he could and rush into his room eager to
get lost in the world of the game maybe
he played a little too much but I knew
he was safe in his room and it kept him
occupied while I made dinner did some
other menial housework
the only real trouble he gave me was
when it was time to eat
just five more minutes mommy he would
beg as daniel matured so did his taste
in videogames by the time he was in his
teens gone were the days of Super Mario
he had upgraded to Xbox and Playstation
when he was younger I played with him
from time to time but our co-op
adventures faded into a distant memory
these new consoles were a bit too
complex for me to fully grasp Super
Nintendo was simple a power switch a
reset button than a simple controller
there was so much more to it now it
wasn't just that though I could deal
with the learning curve if it weren't
for the fact that the level of violence
in some of the newer games was downright
repulsive that Grand Theft Auto game was
probably the worst I'll never understand
the satisfaction one gets from sleeping
with a prostitute only to beat her to a
pulp and take back your money a mere
seconds later really bizarre
unfortunately for Daniel the older he
got the worst his muscular distrophy got
in more severe cases like this those
affected by it will experience a greatly
shortened lifespan often not living past
their late teens to early 20s when he
finally lost the use of his legs and was
confined to a wheelchair he started
sleeping down in the den as to avoid
using the stairs we moved all of his
videogames downstairs and I made up a
nice bed for him in there I would never
let him know it but this killed me
inside I can't begin to tell you how
many mornings I dreaded coming
downstairs
there was one recurring nightmare I'd
have all the time I'd come downstairs to
make breakfast and find Daniel dead it
was a nightmare that I'd sadly have to
live out sooner rather than later
as much as I didn't want to leave my
boys side desperate to spend every last
minute with him until the bitter end it
was important to maintain normalcy as
much as humanly possible and that meant
keeping him enrolled in school looking
back on it I'm sad to say that may have
hurt him more than it helped him they
say kids can be cruel but they got it
all wrong angry bitter teenagers are far
worse Daniels standing out from the rest
of his classmates because of his
wheelchair fell casualty to the school
tough guys how I loathed them there was
one in particular though one worse than
the others
Nick herder he wasn't like the rest of
them he wasn't afraid to get physical he
didn't care at all that Daniel was in a
wheelchair that just made him a slower
target when I realized what was going on
my first instinct as a mother was to
raise some serious hell the school
advised against that though insisting
that the more noise I made would only
paint a bigger target across Daniels
back so against my emotions and my
better judgment I held my tongue and did
my best to extinguish the rage that
burned inside me there may not have been
much I could do but at least Daniel had
his friend Kevin to watch over him
during the school day Kevin was on the
school football team and was familiar
with a few of Daniels bullies usually
he'd step in before things got out of
hand the pair had been friends since
about fourth or fifth grade I always
referred to the boy as the gentle giant
probably the only thing I ever saw him
hit was nails with a hammer that time he
helped me build a ramp for the house to
accommodate Daniel's wheelchair for a
while it seemed as if the boys were
inseparable
whenever Daniel seemed to be having an
extra hard time
Kevin would come over and spend entire
beautiful Saturday afternoons with him
playing video games just to keep him
company and make him feel better over
time though their gaming sessions grew a
bit farther apart with Daniel just
excusing his absences because of having
to go to the gym or some other activity
to stay in shape for sports
it was the inevitability of time people
change circumstances change
one day after coming home from school
Daniel was particularly distraught and
he was covered in bruises on his face
and arms something must have happened at
school I tried to get it out of him but
he just kept giving me the same blanket
statement I forgot to set the brakes on
my chair and I fell honey it's okay I
explained if something happened to you
at school you can tell me I pried for
more information anything I could get
out of him was it the same guys
bothering you again he sat there
motionless as if he was already dead
well fine i huffed I guess I'll just
call Kevin's parents and get him on the
phone I want answers and I'm gonna get
them I'm sure he saw what happened oh
god damn it mom he snapped back I don't
want to talk about Kevin Daniel was
never much of a swearer
I think he was a little shocked to hear
it come out of his mouth he quickly
began to apologize I'm sorry mom I
didn't mean it just could we not talk
about it please I worked my way over to
him and lifted him up cradling his head
on my shoulder like I did when he was
small relax honey I know you didn't mean
it I assured him I could sense him
holding back tears I'm sorry I really am
if there was a way I could take away all
your pain I promised I would we ate
dinner in silence that night at one
point Daniel got a text on his phone it
didn't seem to be anything urgent though
he just glanced at his phone and went
back to eating as if it had never
happened at bedtime I tucked him neatly
into his bed and gave him a kiss on his
forehead goodnight honey I said just try
and get some sleep okay tomorrow is a
better day I know he replied in an
ominous monotone voice at least it was
creepier looking back on it now the next
morning I stumbled downstairs and into
the kitchen to prepare breakfast the TV
was still turned on from the night
before the vexing sound of static
wreaked havoc on my ears
perhaps Daniel had fallen asleep with
the television on wake up sleepyhead
I called I'll have breakfast ready in a
couple of minutes while I was getting
breakfast ready I happen to notice that
the silverware drawer was left open the
Daniel role in here during the night to
get something to eat
hey don't we close drawers around here
still no answer
I entered the den to wake him up he was
really knocked out this morning
I tenderly shook him come on sweetie get
up nothing I rolled him over he lay
there flat on his back his skin was
eerily cold I noticed there happened to
be a substantially dark and sticky stain
on his blanket growing more apprehensive
by the second I tore through his sheets
to investigate the cause as I pulled him
atop the bed my eyes grew broad with
terror
there was blood lots of it flooding from
Daniels wrists a small knife stuck out
of the blankets and plummeted onto the
floor so that was what he had taken from
the drawer I scrambled to call 9-1-1
Danielle's phone happened to be on the
table I grabbed it and slid it open to
call the police that was when I saw the
message he seemingly ignored before it
read you're a pathetic waste of oxygen
you sick freak I tried to see who it was
that was tormenting him but the number
wasn't logged into his phone tears began
to rain down my face as I shouted to the
heavens my scream and the ongoing TV
static forming a demented harmony what
had he done not only had I lost my baby
from a disease but he had forfeited the
battle ahead of time I was a complete
mess during Daniels wake I sat there in
the front row eyes welled up with tears
viewing the world through my sable
tinted spectacles alert enough to know I
was surrounded by people paying their
respects
but doped up enough not to care the
services were just about to wrap up for
the evening when Kevin surprised me
I took my sunglasses off peering into my
swollen eyes he embraced me and for one
moment the memories came rushing back
all the playdates all the sleepovers as
we hugged it felt like one tiny part of
Daniel lived on through his dear old
buddy I don't know what to say ma'am he
uttered he was like a brother to me he
adored you I assured him you really were
a guardian angel probably the only
reason he still wanted to go to school
in the first place he slouched over and
in an instant went from concern to
despondent I should have been there more
maybe I could have seen this coming his
deep drawn-out breaths for the weight of
the guilt and to mning his soul
don't ever blame yourself sweetie no one
seen this coming he leaned over and
whispered as if he was being watched if
you'd been in school you could have
probably seen it coming a mile away what
do you mean
I asked he began that day in school
before he died
I took off early for football practice
we were doing laps in the field that's
when I found him his wheelchair was
flipped over and he was covered in
bruises and dragging himself across the
ground
what the hell what kind of sick animal
would do such a thing my shock had
turned to rage who did this
I demanded to know was it those same
miserable bastards always bothering him
if I had to guess explain Kevin but no
one was around when I found him and he
refused to talk about it he demanded I
get him back into his chair and send him
on his way this explained a lot
if only Daniel had opened up to me about
it we may not have been laying him to
rest now
the first couple of months after he died
was probably the worst time of my life I
was a complete shell of my former self
if I ate anything it was purely for
nourishment to keep me going I dropped
about 15 pounds in the span of a month I
had completely emotionally isolated
myself from the rest of the world
avoiding all contact possible as much as
I didn't want to deal with people
locking myself in the house wasn't an
option either
whoever said silence is deadly new their
stuff it's amazing the things you pick
up on in an empty nest it was just
something weird about the house it was
this bad feeling that you just couldn't
shake I started having these horrible
nightmares
it was the same dream each time
incredibly vivid the television
downstairs would be blasting static I'd
stumble out of bed to investigate and
there'd be these messy footprints
heading down the stairs they were
composed of dirt and leaves and other
elements they'd serve as my guide
leading me into the den where I'd almost
be blinded by the bright snowy static of
the TV beneath the set melted
decomposing Daniel Leafly rubbing his
slashed wrists across the television
spelling out I miss you mom in blood on
the screen he would turn around and we
would lock eyes they weren't my precious
baby's eyes though they were cold
emotionless black holes where his eyes
should be he would flash me the most
sinister ear-to-ear grin and I'd finally
regained consciousness
punched in sweat and almost dead of a
heart attack my nightmares were getting
so bad that it got to the point where
I'd do anything to avoid going to sleep
I'd usually down a whole pot of coffee
if I could help it though caffeine could
only get me so far then came the tears
and I'd wind up crying myself back to
sleep
being a mother was my whole life my
identity I had this insatiable lust to
be in someone's life to be needed again
it would be another couple of months
before I got that chance again one night
after coming home late from work i sat
on the sofa blindly surfing through
channels and nursing a glass of wine I
don't know what came over me but I just
took a good long look at myself takeout
boxes were scattered across the floor
where my beautiful clean carpet once was
a mess of wires and game consoles were
still canopy beneath the television
serving as a painful reminder of Daniels
presence on the six-month anniversary of
his passing it was time I had to move on
with life to some degree and if I kept
everything of Daniels as it was as a
shrine that was never going to happen
I held a small garage sale and got rid
of most of his clothes and shoes holding
on to a few miscellaneous items from his
infancy mostly everything sold apart
from one of his game consoles and a
couple of his old games figuring maybe
Kevin would want them I set them aside
for him he came by later that night
after I called his parents we hadn't
seen each other since Daniels wake how
are you doing I asked doing okay he
responded how are you holding up I'm
going along I suppose there was a
certain awkwardness in the room neither
of us knew what to say to one another I
motioned for him to go sit at the
kitchen table and I brought the games in
for Kevin to inspect there wasn't quite
the same glee in his eyes Daniel had
been getting a new video game but I
could tell he knew his stuff when it
came to this sort of thing he sifted
through some cables and plugs and asked
mind if I plug this in it was a
reasonable request the console hadn't
been played with and so long and it was
full of dust for all I knew it was as
good as scrap
we took it into the den and sat down
next to each other after a couple
minutes of fidgeting with some cables
the game console was up and running
Kevin selected a game and inspected it
closely this one looks like it scratched
a little he had
I wonder if it'll play only one way to
find out he slid the disc in after a
couple of seconds a loading screen
appeared his eyes lit up as the game had
started I probably hadn't seen a smile
like that since Daniel first got the
game even though this was supposed to be
a temporary test run he seemed to be
getting engrossed in it I offered to
make him a sandwich while he tried the
game out but he declined it's okay ma'am
really don't trouble yourself he
insisted as a matter of fact while
you're sitting here you want to see
something cool okay sure I suppose I
answered he pulled out a headset from
amongst Daniels things and handed it to
me this game has online multiplayer he
explained Daniel always bragged about
how good he was at this one I saw right
through him he could tell I was still
upset I was trying to cheer me up by
bringing back a pleasant memory I was
gonna save up money and get it myself so
we could play together unfortunately it
didn't work out like that he continued
before I could interrupt come on why
don't you play a game Daniel what's that
you used to play it'll be fun
maybe play a video game the last time I
did that you still blew in the
cartridges to make them work I grabbed
the controller with anticipation okay so
what do I do
I stared ahead at the screen my
character was some kind of soldier in a
field at least I'll call him a soldier
who else carries a big machine gun he
explained well your red team anyone who
has a red name over their heads is on
your side you got to kill the blue team
you press X to fire the gun in the
beginning I didn't think I was going to
enjoy it much but about 20 minutes in I
could understand why this might be
addicting to some playing the game
myself really shed some light onto
Daniels obsession in reality he was
stuck in a wheelchair and in constant
agony in the world at this game none of
that mattered you could run and jump in
and out of explosions shoot bad guys it
was quite a break from the mundane apart
from the preteen boys shouting at each
other this wasn't half bad
suddenly a voice coming from the headset
startled me
this time the swearing seemed to be
directed towards me hey [ __ ] I
thought you were dead
excuse me I stammered I'm just doing
good at the game I guess beginner's luck
they just had a funeral for you not too
long ago he continued I'm sure of it his
username flashed across the upper right
section of the screen each time he spoke
bring the hurt to k18 Kevin removed the
headset from over me and exchanged some
unpleasantries with this mystery man
Kevin apologized sorry you had to hear
that that was a friend of Daniels in
mine he just wasn't expecting to see the
gamertag again he didn't know who he was
talking to something was fishy he
wouldn't look me in the eyes within an
instant he went from friendly and
playful enjoying the game with me too
clammy and pale quiet as a mouse I
thought to myself for a moment bring on
the hurt to k18 bring on the hurt the
hurt that's Nick hurt her on the end
isn't it I screeched he must have heard
me through the headset you know who it
is baby suck oh how I wished at that
moment I could have pulled this smug
little bastard through the television I
was ready to smash the game system just
to turn it off and not hear from that
kid ever again
when suddenly another voice chimed in it
was a voice that for some reason only I
could hear just five more minutes mommy
come on just five more minutes
that was Daniel's voice his voice is a
child it was the same high-pitched
pleading I used to hear when he was a
small boy and I had to pry him away from
these damn video games I'm so sorry
about this I really am Kevin apologized
you know what it's getting late thanks
very much I'll just pack this up and
take off don't worry about it honey it's
fine I desperately tried to keep calm if
I wasn't stuck to my seat before I was
now that was my baby's voice coming from
that headset and I had to try to hear it
again
Kevon breathes a sigh of relief okay if
you say so but I really do have to take
off now you know what just give me five
more minutes oh god I was starting to
sound like my son now I'm not gonna yell
at the young man or anything no drama I
promise let's just finish the game he
glanced at his cell phone you know what
you just go nuts and enjoy the game I'll
pick it up from you tomorrow thank you
for letting me have it no problem
sweetie I stood up and gave him a hug
thanks for showing me how the thing
works he let himself out while I
returned to the game I called out to
Daniel trying to get him to speak again
sweetie talked to me are you there yeah
I'm here baby what you need his honeyed
words made me sick
he thought I was talking to him joke all
you want I snapped back at him I saw
your texts to my son had you chosen your
words a little bit differently I'd be
pressing charges against you right now
not playing games
what are you talking about his sarcastic
chuckle was broken up by a deep cough I
couldn't stand to be around him during
the day you really think I'd waste my
day time messaging him his coughing
became more profound suddenly his
character stopped moving I was actually
able to land a couple of kills to his
character his coughing was still not
letting up now it was even more guttural
suddenly I could hear screaming coming
from the headset honey what's wrong is
everything okay oh my god get in here
quick dead silence a notice popped up on
the TV screen you were kicked from the
session because the host has left the
game i sat there bemused what the heck
happened did I break the game I flipped
a switch and looked at the time another
two hours had gone by geez time really
does fly when you're wrapped up in these
things that night the nightmares resumed
in their regularly scheduled timeslot
this time something was different about
it when Daniel and me locked eyes he
actually spoke to me that had never
happened in the dream before thanks
mommy
he said in that same high pitched voice
I could have sworn I heard on the game I
joked it up in bed how much longer could
this go on I felt like I was losing my
mind if I had two or three hours of
sleep that night that'd be saying
something
the following morning I dragged myself
out of bed and down the stairs thank God
it was the weekend and there was nowhere
to go
I hoggish ly downed a pot of coffee and
tried to wake myself up I was flipping
through the TV channels when a news
bulletin caught my eye 17-year old
Nicholas herder has passed away after a
late night gaming binge gone horribly
wrong
the victim's parents say they were
getting ready for bed yesterday evening
when they heard strange noises coming
from their son's bedroom the boy's
mother had entered the room to check on
him when she found him unresponsive on
the floor clutching his videogame
controller in his hand
authorities are currently calling his
death accidental saying he appeared to
have been choking on something though no
food or drinks were found in his room an
autopsy is scheduled for later this week
my coffee cup plummeted to the floor a
tiny mushroom cloud of broken glass
enveloped my slippers he was fine just
last night I heard this kid myself even
played a game with him he was there one
minute and gone the next
a wave of guilts rushed over me but I
couldn't understand why it wasn't my
fault the kid was in his own house just
playing video games and he started
choking could have happened to anyone
later that night Kevin came back to pick
up the console almost as if our minds
were in sync we both brought up the
incident he was at the gym when he found
out what had happened how crazy is that
he rhetorically questioned and you were
still playing what had happened yeah I
confirmed he was being a smartass one
minute and the next minute it threw me
out of the game I thought it was broken
at first or something he pressed on with
the questions and it just happened all
of a sudden he didn't seem sick or upset
or anything not at all
I explained if we would have turned the
game off that first time you wanted to
leave I would never have caught it what
a difference that few extra minutes made
the memory of Daniels boys coming
through on the headset suddenly came
flooding back to me just five more
minutes mommy I became very shaky and
short of breath all of a sudden
a concerned gaze overcame Kevin's face
something wrong you okay yes I assured
him I'm just tired I haven't been
sleeping too well nightmares he asked
that was certainly a lucky guess
well actually yes what makes you say
that
I asked as I stood up to go retrieve my
phone in the other room I didn't sleep
too well myself last night to tell you
the truth I was thinking about Daniel
well it's been a while since you've been
around I said from the other room maybe
coming back just triggered some old
memories I was about to enter the
kitchen when I caught a quick glance at
the clock in the den it was just about
dinnertime
are you hungry have you eaten why don't
you stay a little while I'll order
something accidentally I pressed the
send button on the phone it began to
ring and miraculously Kevin's phone
began ringing almost at the same time
hello hello Kevin's voice began echoing
both from the kitchen and from the phone
I never had Kevin's number in my phone
not his cellphone anyway I turned it
over when I realized I was holding
Daniels phone not mine I must have
grabbed it off the table by mistake
I still kept it running so I could hear
him talk through his voicemail he never
left me any voice messages only texts I
went to hang up the phone when I stopped
dead in my tracks I had accidentally
opened one of Daniels old text messages
and it must have dialed the number
you're a pathetic waste of oxygen you
sick freak I entered the kitchen and
Kevin and me locked eyes I suddenly
heard a familiar voice again just five
more minutes mommy the next thing I knew
everything went black and Here I am now
writing this letter looking at all this
blood I have on my shirt I'm afraid of
what I'll find if I go downstairs just
five more minutes and I'll go check
that's all just five more just five more
minutes mommy